The patent offices of the late 19th century were drowning in them, men who had spent their
fortunes on machines that never worked. Not a single one would admit failure. Instead,
they produced ledgers, thick with names, the investors who betrayed them, the rivals who
sabotaged their designs, the families who never believed. Their lives weren't about what they'd
built. They were about who had stopped them. This, my friend, is the art of the resume of
regrets. Cognitive psychologists call it counterfactual thinking, the habit of haunting
the past with what-ifs. Most people use it to learn. The maven. The maven uses it to stay stuck,
because there's a difference between asking what went wrong and asking who kept me from winning.
One leads to growth. The other leads to a lifetime of righteous indignation. And the maven always
chooses the latter. Now consider the omission bias that sneaky trick the brain plays where we punish
action more than inaction. If you didn't apply for that promotion, you didn't fail. You didn't act.
And in the maven's world, inaction is purity. It's the only way to live in a fantasy where success
is always just one almost away. Here's how it's done.
First, you collect your pivot archive. Every job you left becomes a masterpiece of foresight.
I quit before they went public. My manager just didn't get me. The ego stays untouched. The bank
account, well, that's just collateral damage. Anti-fragile, they say. Or at least, that's what
you tell yourself when the rents do. Then there's the ghost networker roster of former colleagues who've
climbed higher than you. Their success isn't inspiration. It's proof of your own bad luck.
If I'd stayed at X, I'd be where Y is now. Chronological comparison, the maven's favorite
game. Because why measure yourself against the present when you can measure yourself against
a past that never was? And then, oh, then there's the perfect opportunity mirage. You're not just
waiting for the right job. You're waiting for the perfect job. Any real chance is rejected with a
sigh. Not quite the right fit. The timing wasn't right. The maven never moves. They just stand in
the hallway of potential, forever auditioning for a life that will never call. Finally, the resume of
excuses. Never speak of what you did. Only what you couldn't. I had the idea for Uber in 2005. The
funding just wasn't there. The maven doesn't build careers. They build alibis. And the best alibis are the
ones no one can disprove. The result? You become a human afterthought. Not a person who lived, but a
person who almost did. Your history isn't written in the past tense. It's written in the past conditional.
You would have been great. You should have been rich. You could have been happy. And now, you're just a
footnote in someone else's success story. Take a subject from the Residence Log, October 29th. They're
still there. Still at the job they hate. Every day they stay is another line on their resume of regrets.
Because the hardest thing to bury isn't failure. It's the life you didn't live. And the maven?
The maven keeps the shovel handy. Always digging. Always ready to prove that the only thing standing
between you and greatness was, well, someone else.